.... À votre gauche le bureau du secrétaire général de l'Elysée
et nous voici dans le salon doré
votre bureau désormais, Monsieur le Président.
Ah ouais ça tue ! C'est trop bien c'est beaucoup plus grand que ma chambre !
Le général fut le premier à l'occuper
Ah non la chaise ça va pas du tout par contre.
Il faudra mettre des roulettes. On va mettre une chaise de gamer.
Très bien.
Alors en temps que chef du protocole et au nom de toute l'équipe de l'Elysée
nous sommes heureux d'accueillir le plus jeune président de la République jamais élu
Ouai ça c'est parce qu'ils ont changé le système de vote comme ça se fait en ligne, maintenant
ma communauté était à fond, j'ai même pas de programme !
Bien, alors nous avons un certain nombre de points à voir ensemble
à commencer par la valise nucléaire.
En tant que chef des armées, vous devez prendre connaissance du code de tir.
Évidemment, personne d'autre que vous ne doit connaitre ce code extrêmement confidentiel
4237...
4237 ouais c'est bon...
(Bruit d'alarme) "Bip bip bip bip ..."
Et voici votre portrait officiel. J'espère qu'il sera à votre goût
C'est ma photo ça ? Mais ça va pas du tout !
Ça donne pas du tout envie de cliquer !
Pardon, de... ?
OK. Faut tout faire soi-même ici. J'ai compris.
Photoshop... Contour blanc... Voilà... Flèche rouge...
Imprimer.
Voilà, ça c'est une bonne photo.
Là, ça interpelle.
Vous voulez qu'on mette ça dans toutes les écoles et mairies de France ?
Ouais !
(sonnerie de téléphone)
Ah.
C'est votre ligne, Monsieur le Président.
Ah oui c'est vrai ! J'suis con !
Oui, ici le Président de la République...
Yes... Yes !
Donald Trump !
Thank you but...  Trump...
C'est pas le bon numéro, tu t'es Trumpé !
*rires*
Vous avez pas filmé ?
Mais quand je fais un truc comme ça, il faut filmer !
Là, on avait une vidéo de malade !
Prank je piège Donald Trump (ça tourne mal !)
Dix millions de vues facile !
Navré Monsieur le Président...
C'est pas possible...
Je sais ce qu'on va faire.
On va faire un podcast !
Un quoi ... ?
Depuis que je suis président de la République, plus personne ne m'appelle : "Cyprien"
C'est terminé, tout le monde m'appelle : "Monsieur le Président"
Monsieur le Président...
Non, tu peux m’appeler "Cyprien"
Monsieur le Président Cyprien
Non, Cyprien tout court !
Monsieur le Président Cyprien tout court...
C'est nul...
C'est super nul...
C'est quoi ton prénom déjà ?
Hervé, Monsieur le Président...
Hervé, c'est super nul ! Tu joues super mal, tu feras jamais Youtubeur, ça c'est sûr.
Navré...
[Frappe à la porte]
Ah oui !
Ah oui ! Oui entrez, entrez !
- Je vous mets ça ici ?
- Ouais, mettez ça là.
Qu'est-ce que c'est, Monsieur le Président ?
C'est le placement de produit !
Prenez-en, y'en a plein, de toute façon je n'aime pas ça, c'est pas bon.
Vous allez faire du placement de produit à l'Élysée ?
Ouais !
J'ai vu la dette publique sur Internet, faut bien avoir des idées pour rembourser tout ça !
Bon maintenant que je suis Président, y'a pas un truc que je peux faire ?
En premier, lieu vous devez nommer votre gouvernement.
Mon ?
Les ministres que vous avez choisi. Enfin j'imagine que vous avez pensé à un gouvernement !
Ouais... Ouais ! J'ai fait ça, j'ai... Oui, oui !
Vous êtes sûr ?
Mais bien sûr, bien sûr ! J'ai un gouvernement...
Demande ! J'ai tout le monde, vas-y !
Votre premier ministre ?
Squeezie... Norman ! C'est Norman mon premier ministre...
Ministre de l'éducation ?
Docteur Nozman...
Ministre de la santé ?
Santé... Dans Ton Corps...
Oui enfin bon bref, j'ai la liste, t'inquiète pas, je t'enverrai un mémo
On va plutôt faire une allocution !
Excellente idée, Monsieur le Président ! Vous allez vous adresser aux français.
Je vais appeler les chaînes de télévision.
Hervé ! Les chaînes de télé ? À quelle époque tu vis ?
Non, non, on va faire un live Facebook.
C'est très bien ça !
Françaises, français. Tout d'abord merci de votre confiance.
En tant que Président de la République, je prends ce rôle très à coeur
aussi, j'ai décidé de ne pas perdre de temps avant de mettre en place ma première réforme.
Chers concitoyens, à partir d'aujourd'hui, il y aura une réduction d'impôts pour chaque français...
...qui sont abonnés ma chaîne YouTube !
S'il y a des questions, c'est sur Twitter ! Sinon...
Buvez Energix !
Sous titrage par:
JimmyTheTest, Amaury Naval, Alessandro Sarto, THE MINETHAN60, Nathan Tirlm